bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur st france vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure un instant le co
président du conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france
demandé à la france de prendre ses
responsabilités dans ce conflit que peut
être justement le rôle de la france la
france depuis de nombreuses années et
coprésidente du groupe de minsk qui est
un groupe constitué de plusieurs états
européens
elle en est vice président avec eux des
états unis donc un peu en dehors de
l'europe évidemment et la russie ils
sont en charge de trouver une issue
pacifique à l'occupation de
l'azerbaïdjan par l'arménie déjà depuis
une trentaine d'années
donc le rôle de la france et bien sûr
devrait à ce qu' il ya une issue
pacifique c'est vrai que depuis 30 ans
aucun progrès n'a été réalisé
les deux membres les tentatives pour
faire respecter les résolutions du
conseil national notre conseil de
sécurité de l'onu n'ont jamais été
respectées
donc on est arrivé aujourd'hui à une
extrême tension
on peut même dire à une situation de
guerre qui est qui est très dommageable
il faut que la paix revienne mais pour
qui happe et fauqué l'injustice et
potiers la justice il faut le respect
des décisions internationales
il ya eu plusieurs tentatives de
cessez-le-feu depuis le début de ce
conflit
pourquoi aucune n'a abouti
je sais pas je suis pas sur le terrain
je j'entends les uns des autres mais les
informations qu'on peut recueillir dans
une telle période difficile qu'il faut
mettre des guillemets informations parce
que on peut plus facilement parler d'un
côté comme de l'autre de propagande
évidemment chacun essaye de tirer chaque
événement à son avantage donc qui
violent le cessez-le-feu qui a commencé
par tirer sur telles ou telles cibles
civiles serre tel ou telle ville
il ne peut vraiment savoir ce que l'on
sait c'est que les deux sont impliqués
et deux parties et que évidemment c'est
pas une situation
facile et c'est pas une situation
acceptable il faut que la raison en eau
viennent et pour ça il faut que l'état
soit une table de négociation avec des
éléments à négocier si l'harmonie vient
pour dylan ou la situation depuis 30 ans
et celle là et on ne veut pas bouger
d'un iota
évidemment la négociation ne peut
s'engager sur un refus de négocier quoi
que ce soit il faut aussi plaisir bad
gens comprennent les attentes des
populations arméniennes qui vivent sur
le territoire de l'azerbaïdjan mais qui
sont actuellement occupées et qui sont
en grande crainte d'une éventuelle d'un
éventuel retour de l'azerbaïdjan grande
qu'elle justifiait pas j'espère qu'elle
n'est pas justifiée mais en tout cas
qu'il faut comprendre mais et craquer
les attentes des populations d'origine
arménienne
il y à des médiations internationales
quel bilan vous en faites est par
ailleurs justement est ce que la
communauté internationale elle joue
pleinement son rôle et médias sur
l'existant particulier la russie a joué
ces derniers jours c'est depuis peu
depuis un à main a joué un rôle
important puisqu'elle a réuni les
belligérants mais faut bien convenir que
aujourd'hui près d'un mois après le
début de l'offensive
certains diront de l'offensive
azerbaïdjanaise ou en tout cas depuis le
début de l'offensive
depuis le début du conflit rien n'a
véritablement bouger les lignes la ligne
de front à bouger les azerbaïdjanais ont
reconquis une partie du territoire qui
avait été pris par les a's et les
arméniens au début des années 90 mais on
est toujours dans une situation
d'extrême tension avec des tirs avec ed
et missiles avec des cibles civiles
qu'ils sont
prise à partie et quelles pourraient
être les solutions à ce conflit c'est
une question évidemment très délicate
difficile disons que la solution est la
partie aux belligérants eux mêmes
nul ne pourra imposer à l'arménie ou à
laser abattre des conditions que l'un où
l'on pourrait accepter
donc il convient que ces deux parties
acceptent de se voir et accepte de
discuter et de ce fait accepte de poser
sur la table un certain nombre de
conditions si l'un ou l'audi et aucune
condition
je veux tout et rien que tout ça ne
pourra pas ne pas convenir
donc il appartient c2 et cas évidemment
de s'entendre je crois pas que aucune
contrainte internationale n'est
aujourd'hui en mesure de pouvoir jouer
sur l'issue de ce conflit
merci beaucoup jérôme lambert député
sociale et de la 3e circonscription à
deux charentes vice présidents des
groupes d'amitié avec l'azerbaïdjan